では よろしくお願いします
で この前 この冗談ででも嘘を言ってはついてはいけないという言葉で終わりました
ですから この前の経典の結論は
まあこのラーフラソンジャに
お釈迦様の息子でしたけど
ラーフルソンジャーに言った言葉で
タスマティヘテーラーフラハッサーピネムサーバニッサーマーティバニッサーミーティエーワンヒテーラーフラシッキタッバン
ですから ラーフルまあ笑いのためにでも
マハッサっていうのは笑いながら冗談でっていうことでね
ちょっと笑ってもらうためにでもね
嘘はつきませんと そういうふうに自分を戒めなさい
今日は
そこからタンキンマンニャシラーフラキマッティヨアーダーソーティパッチャウィッカナットーバンテーティエーウメーワコーラーフラパッチャウィッキッワパッチャウ
ィッキッワカーエーナカッマンカータカッタッバンパッチャウィッキッワパッチャウィッキッワワーチャーイカッマンカッタッバンパッチャウィッキッワパッチャウィッキッワマナサーカッマンカッタッバン
で そこら辺はすごく覚えやすく
まあ教えているところで
タンキンマンニャシラーフラ
ラーフラどう思いますか？キマッティヨアーダーソー
鏡は何のためにありますか？パッチャウィッカナットーバンテー
パッチャウィッカナっていうのはおそらく観察ですね
で 観察するためですよと
だから鏡の鏡は何のためかと我々に聞いたら何答えるんですかね
どう答えますか  顔をチェックする
まあ普通だったらそういうふうに答えますけどね
まあ顔見るためというね
まあ普通の人だったらそこまで言えないんですけどね
だから質問しにくいんですよ
みんなもうあまりの行動に答えるんだからね
まあ大体普通だったら鏡で顔見るためっていう風に言っちゃうんですね
で でもその場合は顔見るためっていうことは普通の言葉なんですけど
言葉としてはそれほど厳密ではないんですね
やっぱり本当は顔をチェックするために
で 鏡があるんですね ですから
このチェックするという言葉が大事なことなんですね
でも一般的には鏡は何のためと聞いたら
そこまでは言わないと思いますけどね
そこでラーフルソンジャはすぐパッチャウィッカナっていう言葉を使ってますね
で パッチャウィッカナっていうのは
このパッチャっていうのは戻ってという意味なんですね
アウェッカナっていうのは見るということなんですね
あれ 遡って見るっていうことなんですね
だからちょっと振り返って遡って見ることがパッチャウィッカナなんですね
ですから 過去のことはもうずっと見ることもパッチャウィッカナなんですよ
でもそれだけに使わない
それだけに使う言葉でもなくて
ただその場でその場で観察することもパッチャウィッカナっていう言葉に使っているんですね
ですから 過去の出来事を観察することもパッチャウィッカナであって
今の出来事を観察することもパッチャウィッカナであって
将来に起きそうという出来事について観察することもパッチャウィッカナなんですね
ですから パッチャウィッカナは観察というふうな言葉にした方がいいかもしれませんし
言語はもうプティアウェクシナですから
プティっていうのはもう後ろですよ
で またもう一回ということで見てみる
もう一回確かめてみるというふうな意味なんです
そのパッチャウィッカナという言葉は
お釈迦様はキーワードで取るんです
そのキーワードは相手からもらうんですね
だから相手が知ってる単語なんですよ
ですから まずラーフルソンジャに鏡は何のためでしょうかと
で 観察するためですよと
その観察という その単語はキーワードとして
それからお釈迦様は使うんですね
ですから そちらでちゃんとコミュニケーションというものは
お釈迦様が言いたがっていることはちゃんと相手も分かってもらうという
そこら辺のこのコミュニケーションというのは成り立つんですね
だからこの会話 対話形式でないと
なかなかこの人が言うことは理解しないんですよね
ですから 質問して質問に答えるということは
まあ一応仏教の場合は常識でもあって行儀なんですね
で 現代は質問するとえらい失礼ではないかというふうに思っちゃいますけどね
ですから 世間の考え方と道徳観と
まあいろいろ違うところもあります
とにかく相手に対しても散々質問する
質問すると 相手はどうしても答えなくてはいけない
答えないならばものすごい侮辱
失礼なんですね それでまあ答えた言葉
そこから相手がどんな単語を使っているかということは
喋る相手わかるんですよ
そこでお互いはどんなレベルで
どんな単語で どんな風な言葉に意味をつけて考え理解しているかってわかったところで
ゆっくりとこちらが言いたいことは相手に伝えてあげることができるんですね
それでコミュニケーションというのは成り立つんです
それでエヴァメーヴァコーラーフラパッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワカーエナカンマンカータッバンカッタッバンエヴァメーヴァ
そのようにラーフラパッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワ
観察して観察してということで繰り返すんですね
カーエナカンマンカッタッバン体の行為
体で何か行動する場合は
よく観察して観察してするべきですよと
パッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワワーチャーヤカンマンカッタッバン言葉で行動するとき
そこで言葉で行動するということは喋ることなんですけど
バハシタッバンとしちゃうとパッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワバハシタッバンといえばパーリ語はパーリ語なんですけど
そう作るとこのあるバランス崩れちゃうんですね
ですから カンマという言葉はもう専門用語で
そこを使ってカーヤワーチーマノという普通に専門用語として整えるんですよ
その方が分かりやすいし
覚えやすいし 混乱はないということで
ですから 言葉で行為をする時も観察して観察してするべきですよと
えーと パッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワマヌサーカンマンカッタッバン心で行動する時でも観察して観察して行動するべきですよと
行為をするべきですよと
心でする行為っていうのは何でしょうかね
考えることなんです 言葉でする行為は喋ることなんです
体でする行為は行為なんですね
行動なんですね しかし
こちらは全部行為に 行為という
カンマという言葉にまとまっています
そういうわけで この段落からお釈迦様はこの嘘についてではなくて
行為全体について カンマ全体について説明しようと頑張っているところなんですね
そこでこの相手は子供なんですよ
で 相手は子供だからといって道徳をほんのわずかしか教えるということは
これはできないんです
とにかくすべて教えなくちゃいけないんです
ですから この それも世間では認めない一つ
仏教ではやってしまう一つの大胆なことなんですね
で 子供には子供なりにいくらか教えて
大人になったらそれなりにいくらか教えてとか
だから教えてないものっていうのはもう大量にあるんですね
世間では だから全てのことはいつ教えてくれるかということは
死ぬまでないんですね
そこで じゃあ年取ったら全部言いますから
そうでもない そうすると
年取った人にいろんな情報をごまかしても隠しておくんですね
その人にそれは言ってはいけないとかね
それは世間で認められている正しい生き方なんですが
それは残念に仏教ではやってないんですね
で 相手が子供であろうか
若者で誰であろうが関係なく
言う時は全て言うんですね
で まあ仏教には仏教なりのね
まあ言い訳がありますけど
まあそれはどういうことかというと
やっぱり子供が親が嘘を言ってるんだよということをよくわかってるんですね
いろんなことをごまかしてるんだと
言ってないんだと 自分に言わないでいろんなことをやっているんだということは
まあ子供は知ってるんですね
まあ子供は人間として自分と親が同じだと思ってるんですね
もう何でも言ってくれるべきですよと
家のことは全部自分ももう知る権利があるんだぞと
という立場で普通はいるんですね
それは知ることはできるかないか
それは別な話で 気持ちとしては自分も一人前で
もう家族の一員メンバーという立場はもう子供は崩したくないんですね
しかし大人はだからといって全部あれやこれやというふうに言ってくれるわけじゃないんですね
いろんなことは言わないで隠しておくと
隠したところはまあすぐわかるんですよ
まあ隠したと 言ってないんだと
それで大人は信頼しないんですよ
嘘つきと そこでモタモタとしとると
また違うことを何か言うんですね
その時も全部言ってないんだぞっていうことはわかってるんですね
ですから 社会に住みても嘘つきやと
ということで信頼できなくなるんですね
学校に行っても教師は信頼しないんですよ
全部言ってないっていうことはわかってるんだから
それで会社に行っても
会社側が自分に必要なことしか言わない
だから 会社の全て全体的なことは自分が知らないと言われていないということになっちゃうんですね
そこで国会に政府になっても同じことで
議員たちは全部知ってるかというと
ほとんど何一つも知らない
自分たちが政府なのに政府の中身は言ってくれない
誰かがそれを隠しておく
それでまあそうやってお互いに隠す隠すという世界で
総理になったら その人は一番最高司令官で全ての権利を持ってる人なんですけど
その人にさえも情報を言ってくれない
隠す で 逆に総理になると
一つ何て言いますか 宣誓するんですよ
この全部機密は絶対死ぬまで言ってはいけないという
だから総理辞めても言わないんです
個人的な話とかね 政治家同士の戦いとか
それは本書いたりはするんだけど
で 総理として仕事をしていた時やったことはもう言わない
総理辞めても 言ってはいけないということになっているんです
ということで 誰が全部知ってるんですかね
誰も知らないんですね
そういうふうです 世界っていうのは
そういうふうに互いどのように騙すか誤魔化すかっていうね
そこで世間が成り立ってるんですね
だから騙すこと 嘘をつくことは素晴らしいことになってるんです
でないと世界は成り立たないと
そこは仏教は認めないんですね
互いに信頼できないんですからね
だから嘘っていうのはない世界が正しい世界だと
嘘があるということは不正ということなんですね
言ったら困ると 知られたら困ると
まずいということだからね
正しいことだったら知られてまずいわけないでしょうに
ですから この嘘で世界が組み立てて成り立っているということは
世界社会全体 不正でまずいことばっかりやって生きているんだということを
論理は仏教の側から見れば
ですね だからみんなもう平気で簡単に嘘つきですよ
だから なんで自分に秘密があるかというと
秘密があること自体 自分が悪いことをやっているんだっていうことはもう決まっているんですね
別に悪いことでなければね
まあどうったことはないんでしょうし
で そういうことで 今の時点ではお釈迦様が自分のラーフラという小さな
まあお子さんかもしれませんですけど
歳としては子供なんですけど
で その子供に道徳というものを教えようとしている
そこで道徳ということは
今の世の中で倫理っていうのは誰にも説明できない
解釈できない 理解できない
もう大変な世界なんです
ですから 子供に説得できるかと
例えば なぜ嘘をついてはいけないかという
そんな人一つ項目でも
世の中では 今の世間ではね
成立することはできないんですよ
だから私が言うのは 道徳っていうのは絶対的条件で語らなくちゃいけないんですね
絶対的条件でなきゃ道徳ではないんだからね
やってもいい時もやってはいけない時もありますよと言ったら
それはもう別にもう相対的で道徳ではないんですよ
嘘を言ってはいけない時も
言ってもいい時もありますよと
殺しては良い時も 殺してはいけない時もありますよ
それは道徳じゃないんですね
だから人は毒は飲むなかれと言えば
もうそれは毒は飲んではいけないんですよ
毒飲んだら死んでしまっちゃうんですね
そういう感じで この絶対的条件でなきゃ道徳ではないんですよ
でも世の中ではこの倫理は随分仏教と違って
かなりもう研究したり
かなりやりますけど 膨大な量があることはあるんですけど
エシックスと言ってね
で 一つも成り立ってないというかね
ガタガタというかね いわゆるはっきり言えばいい加減なことを言っている
自分が自分が人がやって欲しくないことを言っているだけなんですね
世の中にある道徳っていうのは
よくよく見るとこういう風になっちゃうんですね
誰かが嘘をついてはいけないというと
人が自分に嘘をつくのは自分が嫌だから言ってるんであって
人が嘘をついたことで自分が得しているんだったら
まあ別にそれでいいんじゃないかなと平気で言うんです
殺すなかれという場合も
殺すことによって自分たちが損するならば殺すなかれと言う
殺すことによって自分たちが得するんだったら殺せと言うんですね
ですから倫理っていうのは得するかないかというところで
それも私は得するかないかというもうことで成り立っているもので
私が得するものは全部正しいもので
損するものは正しくないと
それで 私はどんどん広げて社会になってきたって同じことになっていて
国になったら同じことになって
国が得するんだったら戦争も正しいでしょうし
国が損するんだったら戦争が間違っていると
そういうふうになります
そこはまあ そこではなくて
すごい厳密に仏教の道徳と語る場合は
ラーフル尊者にお釈迦様がいかにまとめて
何も漏れることなく完全に語っているんです
これから説明していきますけど
これというところを欠けてなく全部教えていると
これを聞いたらラーフル尊者が道徳について小さな子供なのに完全に全部知っているんです
まだ知らなくちゃいかんということは
さらに勉強しなくちゃいけないということはない
これで十分だよ それもその通りで
お釈迦様が一部隠して言ってないということはないんですね
それで信頼関係は徹底的に成り立つんですね
お釈迦様は亡くなる涅槃に入る前にでも同じことをね
私は一つも手で握って置いたことはないんだと
それは仏教の立場なんですね
全部言うということは
だから言ってはいけないと
嘘つきなさいよと ごまかしなさいという世界は
それはすごく嫌うんですよ
だからそれ見ると 仏教は嫌になる理由の一つなんですね
嘘を言わないということ
だから このあなたは神の子ですよとかね
もうとてつもない幸福な人ですよとか
そういう風になんとかなんとか嘘を言うと
それは明らかに嘘なんですよ
本人調べて言ってるわけじゃないでしょうに
その場合はみんな素晴らしい宗教だという風になってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで この簡単な一行でパッチャヴェッキッタ パッチャヴェッキッタ カーエーナ カッマン カッタッバンの一行ですよ
パッチャヴェッキッタ パッチャヴェッキッタ ワーチャーヤ カッマン カッタッバン
パッチャヴェッキッタ パッチャヴェッキッタ マナサー カッマン カッタッバン
すごい覚えやすい そこでパッチャヴェッキッタっていうのはどんな意味でしょうかというと
それは注釈書に頼る必要は何もない
でも相手が相手が使った言葉だから
お釈迦様が使っている言葉ではありません
ラーフル尊者が使った言葉なんです
だから誤解しましたと
それ権利はないんです
権利もないし それも不可能になっちゃうんですね
鏡は何のためかという質問を出してみたら
それでパッチャヴェッキッタという答えが出てきたでしょうし
観察するためだと そこで鏡を見て見ながら
自分が人間が何をやっているかというところから意味を取ればいいんですね
それからお釈迦様はそれで全部終わりますけど
それからこのやり方説明していくんです
ヤ
デーワトワンラーフラカーエーナカッマンカットゥカーモーホーシタデーワテーカーヤカッマンパッチャヴェッキタッバンヤンヌコーアハンイダンカーエーナカッマン
カットゥカーモーイダムメーカーヤカッマンアッタヴァーバーダーエピサンワッテッイエパラヴァーバーダーエピサンワッテッイエウバヤッヴァーバーダーエピサンワ
ッテッイエアクセランイダンカーエーナカッマンドゥックウドゥヤンドゥッカヴィパークアンティサチェットワンラーフラパッチャヴェッカマーノーエワンジャーネッ
ヤーシヤンコーアハンイダンカーエーナカッマンカットゥカーモーイダムメーカーヤカッマンアッタヴァーバーダーエピサンワッテッイエパラヴァーバーダーエピサンワ
ッテッイエウバヤッヴァーバーダーエピサンワッテッイエアクセランイダンカーエーナカッマンドゥックウドゥヤンドゥッカヴィパークアンティエヴァルーパンテラーフラカーエーナカッマンササッカ
んなカラニーヤン
そこでヤデーワトワンラーフラカーエーナカッマンカットゥカーモーホーシ
ヤディーエヴァモシ モシということで
モシラーフラカーエーナカッマンカットゥカーモー
体で何かこういうカットゥカーモーしたくなった
何かを自分の体でしたくなったとしましょう
タデーヴァカーヤカッマンパッチャヴェッキタッバン
そのカーヤカッマンをこの体でやりたくなったことを
例えば走りたくなったとか
座りたくなったとか もう何か体でしたくなったんですね
何かをしたいとなりました
そうしましょう そうすると
その体でやりたかったことをパッチャヴェッキタッバン観察するべきですと
どのように観察するか
次に説明します ヤンヌコーアハンイダンカーエーナカンマンカットゥカーモ
ヤンヌコーアハン 私は今こういうことをやりたがっているんですよと
イダンメーカワヤカンマン
この私のこの体でやりたがっていることが
体の行為はアッタヴィャーバーダーヤピサンワッテーヤ
もしかするとアッタヴィャーバーダーヤ
自分のためにならないことね
自分の損になるかもしれません
ヴィャーバーダーヤっていうのはもう
これは残念なことに日本語の言葉がないんです
英語だったらまあアンベネフィシャルというベネフィシャルアンベネフィシャルというふうな訳はしますけどね
こちらは自己を害することになりはしないかと
まあ自己を害することに
なるなりはしないかな
まあそういうふうに考えなさいと
で 今や今やりたがっていることをもしやってしまったら
これは自分の害になるかならないかと観察する
それからパラヴィャーバーダーヤピサンワッテーヤ
他人の害になりはしないかと観察するべき
それからウバヤヴィャーバーダーヤピサンワッテーヤ
自分と他人の害になりはしないかと観察すべしと
だから何かやりたかったんだからといって
そのまますぐやるのではなくて
観察をしてみる で どのように観察するかというと
自分の害になりはしないか
他人の害になりはしないか
あるいは自分と他人の害になりはしないかというふうに観察するんですね
そこで言葉ダブってるんじゃないんですか？自分の害になりはしないか
他人の害になりはしないか
それだけで十分じゃないんですか
なんで自分と他人の害になりはしないかと
もう一つ入れたんですかね
どう思いますか え？ダブってる感じがしますか？ ええ
瞬間ね  うん ダブってる感じがするかもしれません
でも実はその三つどうしても必要なんです
そこはお釈迦様が全体的に道徳を知って子供に喋るんだから
その三つにしなきゃダメなんですよ
どういうことかというと
お釈迦様が一切の行為を見ているんです
人間にあの 何と言いますか
強いというかね やられる
あらゆる行為を見て だから一切の行為なんですよ
一切の行為に道徳の判決を出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
行為に道徳というのは行為の問題だからね
だからこの場合は 体で行う行為について
一切の行為をに道徳 モラル的なモラル判決するんですよ
だから大変な仕事なんですよ
それで行為っていうのは３種類なんですよ
自分に害する 行為があるんですよ
それから他人に害する行為があります
ということは 自分には害はないんです
それからもう一つあります
自分にも害して他人にも害する行為があるんです
だから行為自体は３種類ですよ
例えば麻薬が私が使う
誰が害します？自分でしょ
そこで私が持っている麻薬を誰かに高い値で売っちゃう
誰が害します？え？他人でしょ
私は得していますから
だからその行為見たっても
自分が害する行為もあって
自分が得して他人が害する行為あります
そこで自分にも害で もう他人にも害する行為もありますよ
例えば自分がもう酒飲みたくてもうたまらない
でも一人で飲むのもなんか気があまりもうそれほど面白くない
それで人に行って割り勘割り勘というんですか
酒飲みたってももういいやと言うかもしれませんしね
それでこの人はいろんな高級なお酒やら
いろんなものを用意して友達を呼ぶ
呼んだら向こうも元気で
もう酒飲みたくはないよ
飲むその気分じゃないと思っても
すごい高価な酒なんか色々用意してあると
じゃあ飲もうかっていう気持ちになっちゃうんですね
そうするとそれでアル中になったりすると
自分もアル中になって他人アル中になってるんですよ
その場合は自分も害して他人にも害になっているんですね
ですから 行為にはやっぱりそういう３種類がどうしてもあるんです
今 人間に関わる場合だけ言ったんですけど
相手は誰でもいいんです
そこで相手が何でもいいと言っても
相手が例えば生命でなければどうしますかと
その時も道徳判決行為だからね
しなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば自分でいろいろもう麻薬を栽培して
自分の庭で自分でそれを取って作って
自分で使うと 相手生命じゃないでしょうに
自分一人の行為で それでも道徳判決は出さなくちゃいけない
行為に道徳判決を出さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから行為は私がやっている行為で
結果はどちらに入るかと
私だけに入るか 相手だけに入るか
普遍的に誰にでも入るかということなんです
そこで観察すると この害にはなるとわかった場合は
アクサラニダンカーヤカーマそこで判決する
このカーヤカーマがこの心
行為はアクサラン 不善であると
ドゥクドラン 苦しみを作り出すものやと
こう作り出すものであると
ドゥッカヴィパーカ 悪い苦しみの結果になるんだと
いわゆる望ましい結果ではない
期待するべき結果ではないということになるんだ
それはもう明確ですよ
害を与えるんだからね
そこでも判決するんですね
これが不善行為ですと
そこで次に言うのは そうやって不善行為だと自分で判決して自分が判決するんですよ
そこはまたすごい仏教のモラル論の場合の特色なんですね
道徳がないか判決するのは自分なんですよ
だから誰かさんがリスト書いて
これが道徳リストだよと
これ守れと そんな話じゃ丸っきりない
例えばモーセの十戒は
神がモーセに十戒を設定して
もし十戒設定しなかったら十戒はないってことになるんですね
神がするなかれと言ったんだから悪いということになっているんですね
それは成り立たないんですね
で なぜ成り立たないかというと
それは普通常識論に持ってきてください
私が言うんだから悪いんだよというのはどんな立場ですかね
これ失礼なところでしょうね
これはなんで悪いか私が言うんだからよ
それ自体道徳違反ですよ
だから十戒の設定は仏教から見れば設定そのものが道徳違反なんですね
私が勝手に決めるんだよと
あんた方は私言う通りにやりなさいというところで
人の自由な判断できる能力をもう権利を奪っているんですね
そこで我々の自由を奪うことが我々にとって害か
あるいは被害か どちらですかね
かえって害でしょうに
だから相手に害を与えているんだから
道徳を設定したその時点で道徳を破っているんですよ
例えば神がモーセに十戒を設定したその時点で
神が道徳を破っているんですね
それにガチャガチャだから破ったんだから
矛盾成り立ったんだからガチャガチャガチャガチャ説明する
もともと人間に自由意志を与えていたんだと
でも人間がそれは間違ったんだと
だからもう戒律作らなくちゃいけなくなったんだと
だったら自分が与えたものを戻しちゃえばいいでしょうに
では 今日から君らには自由意志がないぞと
それなんでできるんですかね
戒律設定するんじゃなくて
我々自由に判決する能力をいただく
また返してもらえばいいでしょうに
だからもう嘘も嘘で だから道徳を犯した原因はそのまま放っておいてるでしょ
まあもしキリスト教によると
人間道徳を犯したのはこの自由意志で
これは悪用して神に逆らったということで
だったら これはこの人々は悪用するんだよと
やっぱりこれはもう取り消しと
した方がいいのに 悪の原因はそのまま置いといて
戒律を守れと というと
戒律十戒で終わりますかね
人間が悪用するたびに新しい戒律を作らなくちゃいけないでしょ
でも増えないんですね
また残念なことに もし最初からもうそれ言ったならば
君らには自由を与えたんだけど
今日は君らたちはもう悪用しましたと
ですから道徳を設定しますよと
これからも悪用するために私は道徳を設定するんだぞと
人間のいろんな行為が変わるんだから
変わるたびに十戒が 100戒になって 1億戒になって
もう一 教会になってとか増えるべきなんですけど
なんで増えないんですかね
ですから そういうのはこの厳密な論理的な道徳にはならないんですね
まあ矛盾ですよ たとえ
まあ殺すなかれ なんと素晴らしい教え方
そんなもうもう論理性ない人が言うことで
そうじゃなくて 厳密に調べなくちゃいけないんですよ
調べてみると 人を殺すなかれと言った時点で言った人が道徳を犯しているんですね
なぜならば その人は創造主だから
創生した人だからね その創造の過程で
まあ失敗したってもいいんだけど
創造はね 失敗しただったら
その原因をなくすというね
例えば我々は生まれつき嘘をつけない
人を殺す気にならないようにDNA変えてもらえばいかに楽かと
よく知らない行為しないように
例えば鳥の中でいるでしょ
カラスもそうでしょうし
まあ夫婦はものすごく互いに仲良く一生生活する
不倫するとか全然ない
それは遺伝的でしょ 全ての鳥たちはそうではないんだけど
いくつかの鳥たちがいるんですね
一生結婚したら もう結婚と一緒になったら
ずっとその相手と一緒に生活して
一羽が死んでも一人でいる
もう再婚しないという
あれ 何の道徳もなく 何の聖書もないでしょうに
あれ遺伝でしょうに だからそんなにも不倫することも悪くて
嘘を言うことも悪くて
殺すことも悪いんだったら
これ作った人がそれはもうDNA改良した方が良かったのに
だからいろんな疑問が生まれますよ
疑いが もしかすると人間が罪を犯すように放っておいているんではないかとかね
人間が罪を犯すことは期待しているんではないかと
そういう疑問もあります
その方が正しいんですよ
その疑問が なぜならば
世界のシステムを見ると
必ずしも人間がみんなもう堕落するように
悪になるように もう溺れるようにできているんだから期待しているんですね
だから仏教から見れば
仏教で言ってるマーラ持ってる特色は完全に神持ってます
まあそれは余計な話で
まあ論理的な話になりませんから
で そこは言ったのは この
ここまで脱線したのは
この判決というか この道徳的な判断は誰がするかというと自分がするんです
道徳かないかと モラルか
まあモラルでないかということは
それで自分がするところに
これ大変ですよ 哲学者に頼んでみたら
いとも簡単にお釈迦様がこれは自分でやるものやと子供相手に教えているんです
それでぴったしもう文句ない状態で教えているところはどうですかと
だから随分言葉単純だからといって
この言葉の裏にあるブッダの知恵っていうのは
これ一つしか世の中に出てこないんだとというのは
そういう話なんです というわけなんです
こんなに簡単単純で もう絶対的にもう最終決断で道徳語っていると
だから逆にできれば逆らってみなさいとチャレンジ他の経典でやります
できれば逆らってみなさいと
例えばこの教えが時代に関係ないでしょ
どんな時代にも同じ論理
今合わないとかね 将来の社会に合わないとか
できれば言ってみてくださいと
だから真理っていうのは地球が丸いと言ったような感じでなければいけません
もう誰にもどうにもどうすることもできないように語らなくちゃ
そこは人間の個人的な行為についても真理として語る
もうどうにもならない
それが法則で真理だよと
そういう風にこの道徳の世界で語ります
だから 皆様にお釈迦様の真理の状況
真理ってどういうものかと
なぜ仏教はアカーリコ
スワッカトゥ・バガタ・ダンモ・サンディッティコ・アカーリコと言っているでしょうね
それなんでアカーリコ
なんでサンディッティコと言うんでしょうかと
これ単純な道徳ぐらいのモラルのことですからね
それにしたっても これはサンディットケでアカーリケでソワカータなんです
もう改良できません これ以上
そこで必要な説明もお釈迦様ご自身
ご自身でやっていってるんです
そこであの害になると
害するものになるんだとわかったら
エワルーパンテーラーフラカーエナカンマンササッカンナカラニーヤン
ササッカンナカラニーヤンっていうのは決してすべきではありません
決して絶対ということなんですね
絶対やってはいけないと
ですから あの三段階で考えてパッチウェッカナチェックしてみる
自分に害するか 他人に害するか
両方に害するか だからそれ以外の行為は人間にはできませんね
私が何か行為すると 自分一人勝手で部屋の中でやる行為もあります
人間も生命も相手じゃないんですけど
でもそれは自分の行為でしょうし
あるいは誰かとの関わりで行為をする
それ以外行為はないんだから
相手が動物か人間かそれは関係ない
他の生命との関わりの行為と自分一人だけでやっている行為という二つしかないんだから
それでチェックするのは
この害は三段階でチェックしてみる
私に害か他人に害か両方に害か
そこでそちらの反対のことにまた行きます
サチ
ェパナトワンラーフラパッチウェッカマーノエワンジャーネーヤシヤンコーワハンイダンカーエナカンマンカッとかむイダンメーカヤカッマンメーワッタッビアバダヤサンワッて
いえなパラッビアバダヤサンワッていえなウバヤッビアバダヤサンワッていえクサラングイダンカーカッマンスクッドヤンシュカヴィパカンティーエワルーパンヒテーラーフラカーエナカンマンカラニーヤン
そこでそれは断続切るべきなんですけど
切ってないんですね それで観察するときはこれ発見するんですね
私は何か体で何かやりたいんだけど
やっぱり観察するぞと
観察するときはアッタネーアッタッビアバダヤサンワッて
自分の害には全くならない
これやっても で 他人の害にもならない
それで自分と他人の害にもならないと
それわかったら それはクサラングイダンカーヤカン
そこで判決すると これは善行為ですよ
スクッドヤン 幸福を生み出すんだと
シュカヴィパカン 良い結果が出てくるんだと
エワルーパンラーフラカーエナカンマンカラニーヤン
あ エワルーパンカーエナカンマン
そのような 体でこのようなことをしたければ
絡み合う それはするべきですよ
そこでこちらで余分になるんだから言ってないところがあるんです
これで完璧なんですけど
もし余計なことを考えちゃうと余分なこと出てくるかもしれない
これから私はこの余分なところ説明します
例えば何か行為があって
自分にとっては害なんですけど
他人にとってはいいことで
どうしようかと それもあるでしょ
そういう行為も 例えば会社の脱税があって
それがもう会社丸ごと脱税したんだぞと言ったら
会社に大変な迷惑になるんだということで
自分がその罪を私が勝手に資料ごまかししましたと
自分が出ると あと 自分がいろんな大変なことをしたことにも判決下るでしょ
自分にとってはいいことじゃないんだからね
その場合は確実に会社もそれを人は勝手にやったこと知りませんということで無関心にもなるし
でも自分がもう会社を守ってあげたんですよ
そういう行為は何なのかね
犠牲なんですけど 道徳判決は
犠牲は このセットで見るとどういう判決出しますか？でもそちらの答えは正しいと思いますよ
まずいと なぜならば自分に害を与えるものは悪いんだから
条件三つも揃わなきゃダメなんですよ
純粋なお互いのない善行為じゃないんですよ
そこで条件一 ダメでしょうに
最初からもうダメになってるんです
二番目合格なんですけど
三番目も非合格でしょ
だから条件に合わせてチェックすると
一番目はバッテンで  二番目はマルで
三番目はバッテンでバッテンなんです
そういうのは一応相対的な
もしかすると善かもしれませんし
もしかすると悪かもしれませんし
はっきりしない行為なんですね
でも モラルを語る場合は
そう曖昧は禁物 絶対条件で言わなくちゃいけない
だからお釈迦様あれで絶対やりなさい
やってはいけないと絶対条件でもう結論出すんですよ
こういうようなことだったらやりなさいよという場合も
この絶対的条件をつけるんですね
ですから もう犠牲になる場合は
すごい判決しにくい曖昧な行為なんですよ
それで曖昧な行為の場合は
仏教だったらどうします？やらないんですよ
でもジャータカなんか物語にあるのは
自分を投げて相手を助けるという話がたくさんあります
たくさんないんです たくさんない
いくつかあるんだけど
それはもうこんなもう愚かな世界でハイライトしてるだけで
たくさんないんです そこで
初期仏教のジャータカ
大乗のジャータカ またものすごい道徳は違いますから
大乗に出てくるジャータカっていうのはすごい感動的ですよ
初期仏教のジャータカよりは
感動的ですけど 感動的がゆえに道徳すごい曖昧でおかしいんですよ
で 今犠牲の話になったんだから言いますけど
初期仏教のジャータカ物語でこの犠牲論が出てくるのは
いつでもリーダー格の場合なんです
はっきりとリーダー格なんですよ
王様か動物の群れのリーダーかどちらかなんです
リーダーって何なのかね
リーダーっていうのは群れを守る仕事なんですよ
自分を守る仕事じゃないんです
だからリーダーが自分の仕事をこなしてるだけのことなんです
でも この動物の群れの一般的な動物はそれはやりません
で リーダーが自分を身を投げてでも群れを守らなかったら
リーダーが悪いことしてるんですよ
自分に与えられた仕事を自分がやらなくちゃいけない仕事をさぼってるという論理が成り立つんですね
だから自分でやらなくちゃいけないことをやることも道徳でしょうし
ですからその場合は成り立つんであって
ものすごい条件の中なんです
もう一つ身を投げた物語があります
このダンマソンダカジャータカ物語
スリランカですごい人気あるジャータカなんですけど
その場合はこのなんとかブッダのね
まあ前のブッダなんですけど
教えがもうなくなるんですね
どうせ仏教っていうのは社会からね
あまり批判される教えになりますからね
ある時期経つと もう誰も知らなくなったって
そこで王様が誰か一人でもこの昔いた
このブッダのね 教えが知ってる人がいるならば教えてくれと
で 調べるんだけど 誰も知らない
何の教えかと それでブッダの教えがない世界で
もう生活する必要もないんだと
生きる必要もないんだと
言って もう全て捨てて森に入る
こんな国を法も知らない
真理も知らない人々の管理もできませんと
虚しいと で 森に入る 入ったところで鬼が現れるんですね
その人は鬼でも何のこともなく
鬼でも誰でもいいんですよ
もう 鬼にあんたブッダの教え知ってますかと
知ってますよというんで
何のことなく覚えてますよと
だったら教えてちょうだいと
そしたら向こうはあのね
私は鬼ですよと 鬼っていうのは人を食うんだと
だからタダで教えるわけじゃない
できませんと だったらいいですよと
私を食ってくださいと
で その代わりに教えを教えてくださいと
言ったら では先に教えてくださいと言ったら
鬼がダメですと お腹が空いて説法できると思ってるんですかと
我々鬼たちっていうのはなかなかもう人は捕まれないし
だからずっと飢えているんだよと
食べ物ないんだから だからもう説法できませんと
だからまず食べてから説法しますと
王様が と言っても食べちゃったら私説法聞けないでしょうと
まあどうしようかと でお互いに話は通じますから
一応 食べちゃったらもう終わりだから
もう説法は聞けないし
でもお腹が空いてるんだから
落ち着いて説法できんと
まず食べるんだと それもそうでしょうし
2人で考えて何かしましょうと
それだったら ということで
鬼は崖の高い崖があって
崖の一番下に座って口を開けている
そこで王様が崖の上に登って
もう崖を落ちる 飛び込む
鬼の口に そこで飛び込む
あの 1 秒で 鬼はブッダの教えを一つ教えてあげると
で それで あ じゃあもう約束
いわゆる何て言いますか
もう成立ですね 商談は
で 王様は何の躊躇もなく崖に登って
もう飛び込むんですよ
鬼もこのアニッチャー・サンカーラというスリランカの場合は
もうどんな子供でも覚えていて
我々は葬式で唱える偈なんですよ
葬式で二行しか唱えません
日本の葬式と違って アニッチャー・サンカーラ
ウッパーダワヤ・ダンミナ
ウッパジッタ・ニルッジャンティ
テーサン・ウプサン・ムソク
それで終わり 葬式は 三回一応唱えますけど
だからこれは子供でもみんな知ってます
その鬼もそれ言うんですよ
それさえも これすごい教えですよ
葬式で唱えるんですけどね
中身はすごいんですけど
人はみんな死ぬんだぞって意味なんですよ
そんなの死ぬって 誰でも死にますよと
大したことないんだと
で そういう世界からね
脱出することこそが正しいんだよという二行ですよ
で でも 王様が落ちると鬼が何のことなく手で王様を取ってるんです
食べてないんです 取って
実は私は あなたはね どれぐらい真剣かと
それ知りたかっただけですよ
で さらにブッダの教えを教えて
鬼と言ったってのはこれは帝釈天なんですね
これアニッチャー・サンカーラというのは帝釈天のすごい好みの偈なんですよ
お釈迦様は涅槃に入った時でも帝釈天がの
何事と言うんですか あれは
弔辞？弔辞として言ったのはアニッチャー・サンカーラという偈なんです
だからもう帝釈天に覚えられる偈だからということで
スリランカでは子供でも誰でも覚えているんです
あんまり頭のいい神として見てないんです
で そのストーリーでも身を投げるんですよ
でもそちらの価値は一人の人の死よりは真理に価値があるんだよという話なんです
なぜならば真理知った人は死を乗り越えるんだからね
そこでその もし食べたならば
王様が道徳を犯したんです
王様にとっては損でしょうね
損じゃないんですよ なぜならば
死の 0.1 秒前でも真理聞けるんですよ
だから真理知って死ぬんだから
それで全うしているんだ
人生は だから損じゃない
得しています その場合にでも
だから仏教をわかるために
ブッダの教えを理解するために
修行するために命かけることは犠牲でも何でもないんです
それこそやるべきものだと
でなきゃ ただ死んで生まれて
死んで生まれて もう輪廻の苦しみは続くだけなんですね
それをやめることは究極的な道徳行為なんですね
輪廻を脱出することは
そういうわけで 時々たまに命を捨てたということはあるかもしれませんけど
これは厳密に計算して
そういうジャータカ物語にできているんです
初期仏教のジャータカ物語というのは
ものすごい計算しているんです
ただ 何かエピソードで
ああ感動しました よかったという気持ちよりも
ものすごい計算するんです
道徳はどうやって語るかというところで
もう一つの犠牲になった道徳があって
この鹿の群れで王様のもう料理をやっている人々は行って
あっちこっちもう無差別に矢で撃って
もう取ってきて料理すると
それでこの鹿の群れでリーダーが菩薩なんですね
それで王様たちが何やったかというと
毎日毎日狩りに行くのは大変だから
村の鹿たちはみんな捕まってやるぞと
いわゆる まあ今もやっているようにね
まあ森に入って動物獲物取って食べるのは大変だから
みんなもう家畜動物育てているでしょうし
そんな感じでしょうと思いますけど
それで森に行って 鹿た村を全部追い出して
あるもう場所をね 追い出しちゃって檻を作ったんです
そちらはもう食べ物いっぱいありますし
水もあるし かなり大きな公園みたいなもんですね
そこで鹿たちがもう生活できる
繁殖しながら そこで行って
一匹取って簡単に で それでも矢に撃たれて逃げる鹿もいるし
死ぬ鹿もいる これはもうすごく残酷やと
リーダーが考えるんですね
人間食べることはもうそれは避けられない
しかし この無差別に鹿たちを怪我させたり殺したりするのは
これは残酷だと 考えるんです
そこで王様が群れをチェックしたところでリーダー見えたんですよ
リーダーが見えたら もうリーダー二人いたみたいんですけどね
あまりにもかっこよくて美しくて気に入ったんです
なんて綺麗な鹿ですかと言ったら
みんなにこのリーダーを決して殺してはいけないんだと
守ってあげなさいということになって
そこでリーダーが二人分けて管理して
そこである妊娠して そこでこのリーダーの鹿が王様に語るんですよ
あなたはね こうやって来て
あっち矢で撃ったり こっち矢で撃ったりとか
それは残酷だよと 損はありすぎやと
ですから どうせ食われるんだから
損を最小限に減らしたいんだと
ですから 我々は当番で毎日一頭一頭出ていきますと
その一頭取って もう殺して食べてくださいと
言って みんなにこの番号というかね
番号札の番号与えるんですよ
そうすると平等でしょうがないんですね
もうたくさん無差別に殺されるよりは
自分の死ぬ番が来たら
もう 4番目は4日目に行くとかの感じで
それでまた新しい生まれてくる
あの まあどうせ子供は殺せませんだから
そちらにまた次から次へと番号入っちゃうし
それである日当番が来たのはこの妊娠しているメスなんですね
このメスは死にたくないんですよ
それで自分のリーダーに言うんですよ
私は妊娠しているんだから子供を産みたいんだと
子供と一緒には死にたくないんだと
ですから 子供を産むまでちょっとずらしてくれと
ただ そのリーダーはそれあなたの代わりに明日死ぬ人に今日行きなさいとか言えませんと
これしょうがないんだと
お前の番だから行きなさいと言うんですね
そうすると このリーダーが頭が悪いんだと
問題解決できんと言って
この菩薩のところに行くんですね
これは分けて管理していたんだから
菩薩も考えて あのメスの気持ちを考えて
そうですね 君の気持ちもわかる
子供産みたいと 子供と子供まで殺したくないというね
しかしですね 君の代わりに私はもう一応殺せませんだからということもあるし
でも君の代わりに誰かに死ねということは
リーダーとしてはそれは言えないんだと
まあしょうがない 何とかしますからと
君は安心しなさいと だから
群れの頼みはちゃんとやるのはリーダーの仕事なんですよ
それで自分で菩薩考えるんですね
王様が自分にはもう一応殺しませんというふうにライセンスもらったんだけど
今は自分がこのメス鹿の代わりやるんだと
行って自分が あの場所に行って首を切るんだから
そちらに行って何のことなく首を入れて待ってるんです
丸太の上で そこで料理する人も
あの あれ なんとか刃物を持ってきて
今日は首切って もう料理するぞと来たら
なんてこのすごいこの王様の鹿ではないか
これ殺してはいけませんと
王の命令だから どうにもならんですね
それで王様に王様 今日は大変やと
王様を殺すといけないと言っていた鹿の王様が
もうなんとか台で今首を伸ばして待ってるんだと
そしたら王様がさっさとそちらに行こう
行って 君はなんで来たんですか？君は殺さないようにしているんだよと
だから帰れと そしたら
いえ 帰りませんと 王様に毎日一頭あげる約束でしたからね
だから今日の当番は何ですかと
あの子はね もう妊娠して子供を産みたいと泣いてるんですよと
ですから その代わりに他の自分の家来と言えないね
自分の群れのリーダーとして他の人を殺すことは
それはリーダーとして失格だよ
殺すこと 当番は別ですけど
だから私はその自分を守らなくちゃいけない人のために
自分の命を差し上げていますよ
どうってことないんだから
まあやってくださいと言って
リーダーの仕事を王様に説法するんですよ
リーダーっていうのは
いわゆる王っていうのはこういうものだよ
国民を徹底的に守るんだよと
自分のために 誰かのために誰かを殺すっていうことはしないんだと
それはリーダーたる仕事だよと政治論を語るんですよ
そこで王様はもう自分も政治家でね
もう情けないと よく教えてくれたんだと
ですから 私は人間の王だから
私の国を動植物も守ること
私の仕事ではないかと言って
今日からは私はもうあなた方は食いませんと
森に帰れと帰させるんですよ
守ってあげるんだと ですから
そういう風にすごいややこしく
複雑で ジャータカ物語はできてるもんなんです
単純じゃないんです だから
リーダーが自分の犠牲になるところで
仏教は政治論を語っているんです
正しい政治って何なのかと
そういうことで 大乗仏教ではありますが
初期仏教ではない 大乗仏教である有名な５つジャータカ物語で有名
人相のジャータカとサンスクリット語で言うんですけど
虎の虎の獲物になったか
あれ自体常徳違反でしょうに
虎の雌が飢えていて 自分の子供を食べ食べようとしているんだぞと
まずそれはありえない話で
動物は喋りましたということはなんとかわかりますけどね
ありえないのは当たり前なんですけど
あまり違和感がないんですよ
そんなに違和感があったらハリーポッターの映画も成り立ちませんからね
それはそれで物語としてはいいんですけど
でも自分の子供を食べるということは
哺乳類動物はだいたいはしない
だからそれはないんですけど
それも一つね あまり動物の気持ちはわかってないんではないかと
書いた人が ばかりか物語書こうと思って踏ん張っただけで勉強が足りんですよ
ちょっとした物語を書くためにも
ものすごい勉強しておかないと
だから私もこのハリーポッターの小説に気に入ったのは
単純に書いてるわけじゃない
ものすごい厳密にある母親が子供にどうとか語る
もう同じことなんですよ
すっごく気をつけて気をつけて
一言葉一言気をつけて書いてるところが
そこら辺気に入ったんですね
むちゃくちゃ英語で英語辞書で全然出てこない単語ばっかし勝手に作って
で 書いてますけど そこら辺でこのでもすごいんですね
そこは一つで それで虎の子供たち
虎の子たちが成長して何になるかというと
また他の獲物を取って殺して生活することだけでしょうし
そこで修行する仙人が死ぬことで
その仙人に何が得られるんですかね
1日でも生き延びて修行すればいいのに
だからそこはもうおかしいんですよ
おかしいんだから また書いた人はまたインチキでごまかしちゃうんですね
そうやって虎の母として子供として現れたのは観音菩薩やとかね
たとえ観音菩薩が現れても
やったことは良くないんですね
そこで それは一つのバージョンで
もう一つのバージョンがあって
虎はもう足の足からもうどんどん食べていくと
でもずっと自分がもう心変わることなくいたんだそう
虎ね 逃げちゃえばいいのにね
そんな菩薩がブッダになったってもバカに決まってるんだからね
だから我々はお釈迦様の菩薩のお話しか信頼しないんです
飢えている熊が襲ってくると
かわいそうやって熊にも餌がないんだぞと言って逃げないのはバカでしょうに
食べてちょうだいと それで何が得られますかね？自分は
そんな場合は逃げるのは当たり前であって
あんた逃げたんだから
もう熊の餌がなくなったんだよとか
それは熊の問題で 私が知ったことじゃないでしょうに
だからそこら辺はこの初期仏教でないと
だから犠牲ということは
本当は初期仏教では道徳じゃないんですよ
それはもうバカということなんですよ
だから実際は この自分が犠牲になっているようにな形であっても
本当の道徳っていうのは決して自分犠牲になりません
例えば 自分の全財産を人々が飢えているのを見て
全財産をもう出しても
食料を買ってみんなにあげたとしますね
なんとなく自分が犠牲になっているように見えますね
そういうのは道徳であって犠牲になりません
ものすごいことをやったんだから
決して自分が犠牲になりません
自分がもうそれから全く贅沢もない
建物も全部売ってしまっちゃって
小さなほんのひと部屋で生活しているかもしれませんですけど
それでもその人は大変な素晴らしい気持ちで
人間として生きていてよかったと
というこの上ないありがたみを感じながら生活できるのです
そういうのは犠牲に見えるだけで犠牲じゃないんですよ
なぜならば 道徳行為から必ずもうスカーミパータ
善果が出てくるんだから
そんなのは決まっているんです
だから善行為に善果ですよ
これはもう方程式で変えられません
もし善果ではなかったら
もう道徳じゃないんですよ
表面的に道徳に見えても道徳ではありません
そういうわけで この曖昧な行為は仏教は認めません
善か悪かとはっきりと 2つに分けられますと
では ほっぺたが痒い 自分でかく
それも行為でしょ 体に
それは 善行為ですか？悪行為ですかね
あるいはどちらでもないただの行為ですかね
ただほっぺたかくだけなんですけど
どう思いますか？だから判断しなくちゃいけない
善行為に判断しなくちゃいけないんですよ
結局は だってそれは自分にとっていいことだから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想中痒くなっても
私は一応体動かしてはいけないと言ってますけど
古い方々聞いてないかもしれませんだけど
新しく指導する人々には言ってます
それでもいくら苛立ちが出ても
きちんとそこの方感じて確認しなさいと
そうするとほっぺたがかゆい
痒くことは善行為だったら痒い
しかし掻けない それは悪行為ではない
どうなりますか？もしほっぺた掻くことは善行為だと私は決めたんだからね
自分にとっていいことでしょうね
瞑想している時は掻けない
イライラするんですよ
痛みは我慢できるんだけど
痒みなんかは我慢できんだからね
それでも掻けないで実況中継してみる
どちらにするんですか
それは 私が聞きたいのは善行為ですか？悪行為ですかと
モラル判断 うん だから瞑想中だからではなくて
自分が自分の性格 忍耐
修行ということで頑張ってるんですよ
だからそれが自分にとっていいことなんですよ
この上のない だからその場合は掻けないことは善行為で
掻くことは悪いことで
我慢もしない人間だからね
精進もしない人間だから
もう怠け者で だからその場合は掻くことは悪行為で
普通はほっぺた痒ことは善行為で
そういうふうにモラル判断をするんですよ
だからあくまでも基準は脱線しません
自分に害するかしないか
他人に害するかしないか
両方に害するかしないかと
だからもうしっかりとできてますよ
全部 そこでいつでも個人にずっと判断で判断できる自由っていうのはずっと守っているんです
ですから もうこの法則
方程式知っていけば みんなモラルのプロなんですよ
誰にも頼る必要ないんだ
自分でもうこれが悪い
これが正しい すぐ判決できるわけなんです
それは曖昧の行為の場合なんです
今の説明は こちらではそれは入れてない
入れる必要ない もう決まってましたからね
条件三つでチェックするんだから
もう我々はそれをチェックしないんだからね
例えば犠牲になって人を助けてあげることはどういうことかと
やっぱり自分にとってはといえば×でしょうし
自分と他人の×だったらそれまた×で×でしょうし
項目だけ合格 合格しているんですから
やっぱりもう3分の2でダメで3分の1はOKでしょうしね 3
分の1ではOKになりませんね
そこで面白いことね 3
分の2って成り立たないんですよ
そこまたすごい不思議なんですね
今条件三つでしょ 一は×
自分が犠牲になって会社のためか人のためにも頑張るんだと
それで他人ののためにはなりますね
それで二番目はマル 自分と他人のためになるかというとバツ
それで道徳でないということには
投票が二つと道徳やということと一つでしょうし
だから3分の2でも否定されてます
すごい否定なんです では3分の2で肯定されるケースがありますかね
一つの条件はバッテンですけど
条件二つマルやと 考えてください
成り立たない それもまたお釈迦様のすごいところなんです
曖昧な道徳は成り立たないんです
どう考えても 世の中のどんな行為を見てチェックしたって
だって二番目は他人のことでしょ
自分の行為を受ける側でしょ
三番目は自分と他人両方入れてるんだから
一が飛ばしたら自動的に飛ばしてるんです
二が飛ばしたら自動的に三も飛んでいるんです
だから成り立たないんです
つなげてるんです だからそうするために
そういうふうにすごく計算して
言葉から何から何まで考えてできてます
そこで一つ終わり これから簡単ですけど
やりたかった時なんで
今説明したのは まだやってないんです
行為をする以前 まだやってない行為をする以前
チェックする
次にカロンテーニピテーラーフラカーエーナカンマンタデーヴァテーカーヤカンマンパッチウェッキタッバンヤンヌコーアハンイダンカーエーナカンマンカロミーイダ
ンメーカーヤカンマンアッタヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティパラヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティウバヤヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティアクサランイダンカ
ーヤカンマンドックウドヤンドックアヴィパッカンティサチェトワンラーウラパッチウェッカマノーエワンジャーネーヤースリーヤンコーアハンイダンカーエーナカン
マンカロミーイダンメーカーヤカンマンアッタヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティパラヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティウバヤヴァーバーダーエピサンワッパティアク
サランイダンカーヤカンマンドックウドヤンドックアヴィパッカンティパティサンハレーヤースイトワンラーウラエヴァルーパンカーヤカンマンというところまで
そこは長い文章長いんだけど
言葉としてはカロンテーナピテーラーウラ
それから道徳的に善行為だと決めたものはするでしょうね
それでカロンテーナっていうのはしながら
その体でやりたかったことを今やってるんですよ
このやりながらも観察するべきですよ
やる前に あ これはいいことだと決めちゃったらやるんですが
いいことだと決めたことをやるときも
その最中でもチェックするんですよ
これが私のために本当になるんでしょうかとかね
人のためになるんでしょうかね
両方のためになるんでしょうかとチェックするべきですよと
そうすると やってる最中で発見したならば
やっぱりこれやってもためにならないなと
害になるんだぞとわかったら
アクサランイダンカーヤカンマンこれがアクサラ不善やと決めて
最後にパティサンハレーヤース
すぐやめなさい 途中でストップしなさい
一旦道徳だと決めたら
もう全く徹底的にやるぞってそれもないんです
道徳だと決めたならば
もうもう何もかもやりなさいということではないんです
やる途中でも観察するんですよ
これはなぜかと やっぱりやる以前は推測ですよ
害になるかならないかということはね
だからまだわかって まあ推測だからかなりできますけど
でも実際にやってみなきゃわからないんですよ
結果っていうのは だから種買ってきて
この種を植えてちゃんと面倒見れば美しい花が咲くぞっていうのは推測であって
実際にやってみなきゃ美しい花が咲くか咲かないかわからんもんでしょ
ですから  2番目のチェックも必要なんです
やりながら 行為をやっている最中でもチェックをしてみるんですね
そこでわかって止まっていただけると
もう罪を犯さずに済んじゃうんですよ
だから道徳は徹底的に厳密でなければいけませんと私は言うのはそういうわけなんです
曖昧はモラル論ではもう絶対ダメです
曖昧で実践というのは成り立ちません
曖昧の車の運転とか 曖昧の機械の組み立てとか成り立ちませんでしょうに
何か機械を組み立てるために何かもうネジ一つ
まあまあそこそこまあ 1 ミリとか
まあ 1 センチ 2 センチぐらいどちらでもいいんですよとかね
わけないでしょうに どんな釘でもいいんだよと
こちらには そんなわけないんですよ
ただ単にちょっとした機械組み立てるときでも曖昧ではダメなんですよ
すごい曖昧世界は このコンピューターソフトウェアなんですよ
だからどれほど世の中困っているかという
私のプロバイダーからメールがありましたけど
なんかこのアクセスする人々のどこかのコンピューターがウイルスに汚染していて
自分のメインコンピューターが壊れるんだと
いずれに ですから 自分たちのコンピューターをチェックしなさいというふうに
すごいリストがありましたけどね
私のコンピューターからウイルスはいけませんからね
一応チェックはしていますけど
コンピューター自動的に全部処理しますけどね
メールさえちゃうと でもそういうふうな曖昧なね
もう穴がいっぱいあるんだからそうなってるんですね
それで世界は大変損する
そうやって曖昧に飛行機作ったらどうですかね
そういうわけで やっぱり曖昧っていうのは実践の世界では絶対無理なんですね
澤野さんもいますからね
曖昧に設計したらどうなるんでしょうかと
それは大変困るでしょうし
ですから これはもうもう 200 センチやと言ったら
これは 200 センチでなければいけませんし
これぐらいのこれぐらい材料はこういうところ使いまして
それはもうどうにもならんことでね
曖昧はダメなんですね
それで道徳も生きることだから
曖昧は認めないと だからこの人間
このすごく曖昧でガチャガチャっていうのは
これはすごいけしからんと思いますけどね
そういうことで とにかくこのやってる最中で
最初は設計しても 実際にその設計通りに動いている途中でまずいなと分かったらすぐ変えないと
でも決めたんだからやるんだぞというやり方はね
良くないんですよ なんとか新幹線の場合はそういう問題が起きたでしょ
止めてますけどね どこかの延長線でね
あれはすごいお金がかかっても
もう全然役に立たないということで
でも決めたんだから これぐらいお金を入れたんだから
とにかく作るぞという風に言われていて
そういうのはやっぱり途中でダメだと分かったら
そこでストップすれば亡くなったお金だけで済みますからね
それでまたお金入れて作っても
結局さらに毎日毎日赤字が増えるだけのことになって
どこまで赤字になるかという切りがなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 設計する時点では
例えば日本どこにでも新幹線引くぞと言ったら
これはかっこいいんですよ
どこにでも軽々行けるんだよということで
いいことなんですよ それで設計図も書いてやってみようと思ったら
これは永久的に赤字で走らなくちゃいけないとわかると
そうもう切りがないんだからね
まあそれで中止したらいかがでしょうかということになったところで
またもうガチャガチャ言うんですね
ですから やっぱりどんな計画でもやってる最中で
またわかるんですよ うまくいけるかないかということはね
わかったらまあ あるいはやってる最中ではなくて
計画段階でわかったもんですよ
でもそれは無視しただけのこと
だから損しただけのことですね
あれぐらいのこと 計画段階で何のことなくわかりますよ
そこで逆にこの体の行為をやっている最中で
あ この行為はやっぱりいいんだとわかると
そうするとまあ元気でやり続ければいいんです
最初は道徳だと決めて
3 原則も揃っているんだと決めて
道徳やります やっている時も観察すると
あ なるほど その通りだ
予測通りだ 私のためにもなるし
害を与えませんし 他人に対してもまんざら害もなく良いことやと
とわかれば もう元気でやればいいんですよ
すごい自信を持って そこでアヌーパダッジェーヤース
トゥアンラーフラエーワルーパンカーヤカンマ
で 百十六ページのもう下の方なんですけど
三分の下から三分の一ぐらいのところでカッツーアピテーラーフラカーエーナカンマンタデーヴァテーカーヤカンマンパッチャウェッキタブバンヤンヌコーアハンイダン
カーエーナカンマンアカシンイダンメーカーヤカンマンアッタヴァーバーダーヤピサンワッタイティパラッバヤバーダーヤピサンワッティウバヤッバヤダーヤピサンワッ
ティアクサラングイダンカーヤカンマンドゥックウドダヤンドゥッカウィパカンティサチェトゥアンラーフラパッチャウェッカマノーエワンジャーニーヤシヤンコーアハ
ンイダンカーエーナカンマンアカシンイダンメーカーヤカンマンアッタヴァーバーダーヤピサンワッティパラッバヤバーダーヤピサンワッティウバヤッバヤダーヤピサン
ワッティアクサラングイダンカーヤカンマンドゥックウドダヤンドゥッカウィパカンティエーワルーパンテーラーフラカーヤカンマンサッタリヴァーヴィッニュースーヴ
ァーサブラマチャーリースーヴァーデーセタッバンウィワリタッバンウッタニーカタッバンデーセットヴァーウィワリットヴァーウッタニーカットヴァーアーヤテンサンワランアパッジタッバン
そこで次のセット これえらい厳密ですよ
カッツーアピテーラーフラ
カッツーアっていうのは終わった
体の行為をもうやって終わりました
いわゆるしてからでももうやって終わった
途中では分かりました
いいことやいいことやとわかったところでさささっとやって終わったんですね
でも いいことをやって終わって
それで終わらないんですよ
道徳の判決は 終わってからもう終わった出来事だからちゃんと判断できます
途中の判断ももしかするとわからないかもしれませんね
やった分は良かったんだけど
これからやる分はどうか分からないでしょうに
ですから やってる間でスーッとチェックしながらやりますけど
一旦やって終わってからもう終わった出来事だから
もう当たり前  百パーセント結果が見えるはずなんです
ですから やってからもチェックするんです
この私が行ったこの行為は
私のに害になるかならんか
他人の害になるか あるいは両方の害になるか
チェックしたらこれ害だとわかったならばどうしますか？と
やる前には良かったと思ってやったんですけど
やってる途中でも良かれと思ってやっていたんだけど
やって終わったらもうまずかったと
だったらどうしますかね
もうやって終わってますよ
もうやり直しはできませんでしょ
終わった出来事だから
終わったことにやり直しはない
このやり直しっていうのはあんまり意味がないあの言葉で
本当はやり直しじゃないんですね
まあもう時間的にも通ってる
新しくやることになりますけどね
例えば人の家の前で木が一本あると
自分にもこの木がの木があるんだから
まあ遊べないと で この木はちょっと弱くて
この家の家にも倒れる可能性もあると
そこでその人はこれがなくなったらよく遊べるんだと
ここら辺で私にも はすごくいいことやと
でもこの家の人々にとっても
これ風でも吹いて このこの木が家の上に落ちちゃうとね
人が死んじゃって大変やと
それで自分のためにいいことで
人のためにいいことで話し合ってこの木を倒しましょうと
人がそれでもう考えて木を倒しちゃう
倒す時でも別にいいことはいいことや倒すでしょうね
一旦倒して木をもう分断して
まあなんとか処分したと
それからその家がもう風が当たるは
日が当たるは 雨が降るわとかね
大変残酷 家の状態は 自分もよく遊べるんではないかと思ったんだけど
暑くてもう泥だらけでなかなか遊べなくなっちゃったと言えばもうまずいでしょうね
結果が でもやり直しはない
できないでしょうに ではあの木はまた植え直すぞと
もうもう分断してもう捨ててるんだからね
ですから 一旦終わった出来事をやり直しはできないんですよ
それで良かれと思ってやったことは
やってからも観察しなくちゃいけないんですよ
なぜならば この判断が完璧にするためなんですね
やる前には推測的な判断で
やってる途中ではまあいくらかの経験済みの判断で
だからまあ五分五分の判断でやって終わってからの判断はもう完全な判断できるんだけど
やり直しはできません
それでもちゃんとした判断することは必要なんです
ですから やってからも自分が行った行為が害になるかということは
害にはするかしないかと判断しています
そこで悪かったと判断になったらどうしますか
エアルーパンラーフラカーヤカマサッタリはヴィンニウスはサブラマチャーリースデーセータッバ
そこでラーフラソンジャがもう比丘だからね
出家だから責任者はお釈迦様なんです
あるいは年上のヴィンニウス
智慧のある仏教はよく勉強しているサブラマチャーリー
あの先輩のお坊さんたちなんですね
責任者は デーセータッバ報告しなさい
だからごまかしは禁止
自分が良いと思ってやったんですけど
やっぱり結果が良くなかったと
悪いことやと 不善でしたと
だったらちゃんと自分の責任者にそれを正直に報告しなさいと
ヴィワリタッバン 綺麗に明確にオープンにしなさいと
だから罪隠すことは絶対認めない
だから罪を起こせるということは
仏教は認めるんですよ
こういうふうに厳密にチェックしたっても
やって終わってからはあれまずかったということはあり得るんですよ
だから罪を隠すことだけはやるなよと
報告しなさいと ドーンとヴィワリタッバンオープンにしなさい
ウッタニーカータッバン
ウッタニーっていうのはこの隠すの反対ですね
あらわにするという ですから
つの言葉使ってます 同義語はね
デーセータッバン報告する
ヴィワリタッバンオープンにする
ウッタニーカータッバンあらわにすると
いわゆるはっきりと報告しなさいと
隠すなかれと そこでデーセーとはヴィワリとはウッタニーカとは
そうやって報告してからアーエティンサンガランアパジタッバン
アーエティン二度とそういう行為はしないと
もう経験済みだからね
このような体の行為はもう悪いと
もう知ってます 百パーセント
ですから二度としないというふうなことにしなさいよと
だから完璧な道徳語っても間違いは起こせる
間違いは起こしてしまう可能性があります
そこもちゃんと知ってます
間違いないないか やって終わらなきゃわからないんだから
いくら気をつけても どんなものでもやって終わらなきゃ正しい結果がわからない
で というわけで 人間の行為はまあどれほど厳密に道徳でもうチェックしてもらっても
まあそれでもダメっていうことはあり得るんです
そこで仏教はそれは隠すなよと
隠さないで堂々と報告すると
それが道徳なんです それで他の人もそれ勉強になるでしょうし
で 自分ももう勉強だったになったんだから
もう二度としないという
すごいしっかりした人格が生まれてくるんですね
だから懺悔なんで これは懺悔ということなんですね
お釈迦様にか先輩のお坊様方に報告しなさいと
ですから罪を わざと罪を犯しちゃうと
もうこれはもう認めませんですけどね
その場合は罰与えます
でもわざとではなくて
何かやったことが過ちになってしまったと
場合は報告するだけで十分ですよ
確認というわけじゃないんだからね
それで自分にとっては結果としては罪になりません
それで観察したところで
やって終わってから これは自分のためにもなりますし
他人のためにもなるとわかったならばスクデリアスコイパーカン
大変な良いことだと これまあページで最初の段落スクデリアスコイパーカンって
これはいいことやと やったことはいいことでしたと
わかったならばテーネールタンラーフレピーティパムジェーマ
その喜んでピーティパムいいことをしましたよと素直に喜びなさいと
ビヘレイヤーセ いいことをしたんだと喜ぶ
すごく素直に喜んでアホーラッターノセッキー
昼も夜もいわゆる日夜
そのような生き方をするんだよと
クセレスダンメエス 善行為をすることに
私は昼も夜も頑張るぞと
今もやったことで良かったということで喜んで生活しなさいという風に
この幸福に生き生きなさいよと
それが体の行為について
やる前にも やっている最中でも
やって終わってからも
あの三つの条件でチェックする
だから行為だから これは修行だけに限っているものじゃないんです
一切の行為に対して 日常どんな人間でも実践しなくちゃいけないことなんですよ
仕事も行為でしょうし
三原則でやらないと あらゆる行為
すべて行為といえば もう道徳モラル判断はしなくちゃいけない
会社が儲かるんだからといって何かしたら
それはダメなんですよ
三原則で会社も儲かって
作った品物が使うお客さんの役に立つか立たないかと
払ったお金の分 その品物が仕事してくれるかないかとかね
それだけで終わらない
その私とあなただけではね
それは一般的にみんなの役に立つかと
例えば会社が儲かるんだから鉄砲を作る
ピストルを作る それはすごい上等なものを作る
簡単に隠しやすいとかね
狙いは定めやすいと 今もできてますからね
目で見ると なかなか目もゆらぎありますから
狙ってもちゃんと打てない場合ありますから
今はこの赤い光線で当てたらちゃんと光が赤い光線がまっすぐだからね
レーザー光線は 普通の光よりも
そこで狙い定めると そこで光当たっているところに
ただ引き金を引けば当たるんです
引く瞬間で手をちょっと固定するだけのことで十分です
だから目で見る必要もない
こうやっても打てます
ただ 他のどこ見ても光でちっといきますから
そこもピントなんですね
それで撃てばいいんです
昔のピストルだったら
自分でちゃんとこうやって定めないと
そうやってすごい技術開発してピストルを作ると
で 買うお客様すごい満足でしょ
道徳ですかね そんなので一般的にはどんな結果になるんですかね
人死ぬんでしょうに ですから
私が儲かる あなたにも役に立つだけでは成り立ちません
奪うっていうのは 私と他人
両方まとめたところなんですよ
いわゆるみんなのためにということなんです
みんなのためになるわけじゃないんですね
だからはっきりとピストルを作ることも開発することも非道徳で罪で
買うことも罪で で 決められます
で これで体の行為で まあここら辺で終了しますか
次はそんなに同じことの繰り返しなんですけどね
まあ今日で覚えてほしいのは
このまた道徳の三原則
また後で説明しますけど
今回は次回 今回じゃない
説明しますけど 今日で覚えてほしいのは
行為をやる前の計画段階の判決と実行中の判決と実行後の判決という 3つのところで判決すること
そこでいつでも非道徳だとわかったら
すぐその時点でやめる
それから実行後 非道徳やと不善やとわかったらもうやめるということは成り立たないんですね
その場合は隠すことをしないで
ドーンとそれを発表して
責任者に ちゃんと発表して
それは有効に使う これからの生き方に有効に使う
そうすると一応結果が悪くても
それがまた次に良い方向に使えるんですね
ですから たとえ罪が失敗が起きても
損にならずに済む方法になるんですね
失敗はしたんだけど まあ損にはならないと
それからしっかりするんだということになるんですね
で 話はそこら辺で終了いたします
じゃあどうもありがとうございます